[Music]
according to the New York Times
Secretary of Education Betsy DeVos is
considering a plan that would provide
federal funding to help arm teachers
predictably the left reacted with
outrage teachers don't want guns they
know it makes them a target if God
forbid a shooter comes into the school
and now de Vos wants to take federal
funds away from instruction so that the
school district can buy guns for
teachers what is that all about
Senator Schumer knows not what he says
and nor is he giving a proper
representation of what the secretary is
trying to do but joining me now for a
debate is guns down executive director
igor Volsky and laura Cardo founder of
faster colorado I think you both for
being here
Igor I get the idea that you advocate
and don't want any guns in any schools
and I wish the bad guys wouldn't bring
guns into schools or really anywhere
well look we're on the same page I think
we should have a country with fewer guns
a country where guns are significant for
country look at our same page Jay said
no I think you're utopia that you
described is is just fiction and it's
not reality
so let's pretend that somebody does
bring a gun into the school then what do
you advocate well I mean if somebody
brings a gun into a school that
situation should be dealt with but what
we know is that when but how but how
well I mean it depends on what happens
if somebody reports the student he's
going to be dealt that way if he starts
some kind of incident certainly police
are going to be called but in terms of
arming teachers right which is the
question here what we've seen time and
time and time again is that individuals
who are carrying firearms do not respond
well in an active shooting situation the
adrenalin that runs through your body in
those moments without the proper
training that professionals have in this
field you're not going to be able to to
handle this well and oftentimes innocent
people get hurt so this Court
relation between the coordinates of
people returns if there's nobody on yes
sir is there more people getting
potentially hurt if there's no
resistance or is there if there is
somebody who's there to protect maybe
themselves and their you know the the
FBI actually looked at this very
question they looked from 20 from 2004
to 2013 at active shooting situations
and they actually found that unarmed
individuals were far more successful at
disarming you know what shrewder have a
gun with me too so Laura let's get your
perspective because faster Colorado
you've dedicated part of your career
here in your efforts to actually help
engage teachers how would you see this
working yeah and it's working today
we've got hundreds of armed school staff
already in Colorado and thousands across
the country and and what it comes down
to is these are our school staff
teachers janitors whoever they would die
to protect their kids and in all of
these school shootings you see they're
dying to protect kids they can protect
kids and live and be able to save kids
and go back to their own families and in
you know we hear a lot of these
statistics they're not completely
accurate what we do know is that when
somebody is there on scene to stop the
killer as close as possible to where he
starts his crime fewer people are hurt
or died the the alternative is you have
to wait for law enforcement and if it's
even three minutes most of these things
are over in three to five minutes that's
a lot of people dying with nobody there
to stop a shooter and egor this is where
I think you're wrong because it will
take law enforcement even just a few
minutes in the carnage that can ensue is
just so wrong when I went to school up
in Middle Park at in Granby Colorado a
small school I had Coach Schmitt gets
what Coach Schmitt knew more about guns
than probably anybody I've ever met and
no and him wielding a gun or having a
little sidearm I think would have made
us a lot safer guns are for everybody
you got to have an aptitude and a desire
but nobody's suggesting that every touch
every teacher do this what's wrong with
coach Schmitt having a gun in the school
well listen if that coach has
right amount of training maybe we can
even think about it but I think we can
all agree that guns are too easy to get
in this country that we should just
agree with you that gets into the school
we gotta make guns harder to get because
all the data shows us that fewer guns
means safer communities and you talk
about our utopia you know all other
high-income countries I don't look
what's going on so many times guys I'm
happy to talk about Chicago but you're
the one who brought up our utopia this
idea where you can live in a gun
violence free world and I'm telling you
nations around the world are living that
utopia and they're living it because
there are fewer guns cuz you're a
hundred yet Laura how do we best protect
our kids what's the right thing what is
the right policy for schools yeah we
protect our kids the way we protect our
families and people can make decisions
to have a school that doesn't have armed
staff and does have armed staff and
parents can choose but for my kids for
my grandkids I want somebody there who
can stop whatever happens whether it's a
fire whatever other danger including
active killers and what we know about
active killers Jason is that the next
ones out there he's already planning his
crime no amount of gun control is going
to stop him so what are we gonna do when
he comes to the the door of the school
gets into the school like we keep seeing
somebody has to be there to stop him or
we're gonna see more kids die and more
school staff die and you're right and
we've got janitors who are all over the
school coaches they're all over the
school there are lots of folks and in my
training program we see them the they're
all volunteers they they raise their
hand and they say pick me to save kids
that's what we should be looking at
we've got a lot of former military
people we got a lot of former policemen
that should be involved in engage I
think the right answer is not for
everyone but those that are trained and
those with an aptitude I think should be
in those schools and I'll make those
schools safer I thank you both for your
passion on this issue and coming on the
air to discuss it tonight